[MUSIC PLAYING]
[APPLAUSE]
DAVID MITBY: Good
morning, everyone.
I'm David.
I'm a PM here at Google
working on app ads.
I really love having I/O
right here in our backyard.
It is not even just
Google's backyard.
It's actually kind of
mine because I've actually
lived here in Mountain
View for about 16 years.
And so when I see those tall,
white peaks of the Shoreline
Amphitheater tent, it
really kind of signals
home to me whether
I am at a concert
over there, landing at
the San Jose airport
and I see it off
in the distance,
or enjoying a nice bike
ride on the great trails
that we have right
around this amphitheater.
And when I see that Shoreline
tent, the really iconic tent,
especially in the weeks and
months that are leading up
to I/O, I get really excited
about all the product
announcements that we're
planning to make here,
and I also think for-- and
probably more importantly,
to all the great conversations
that we get to have with you,
engineers, developers,
marketers, product leaders
from all around the world.
One of the big
themes that's really
been coming up in
the conversations
that I've been
having is how mobile
is changing everything and
particularly mobile apps.
I think back to when I first saw
that Shoreline Amphitheater 16
years ago when I moved to
Mountain View, the phone
in my pocket didn't
even have a data plan,
or even almost seven years ago
when I joined Google here just
down the street, I had just
a few apps on my phone.
And I was still doing
most of my transactions
on my laptop, even desktop.
I was going to physical
locations to do business.
And I think to the last
year or certainly two years
everything has
completely changed.
I can't remember the
last time I actually
went to my bank or my insurance
company or even an ATM,
cashing checks on your phone.
If I need supplies, just
a few taps on my finger
and usually within the same
day they show up at my house.
You need a ride, a
couple of taps and a car
shows up to take you to
where you need to go.
I have young kids and so
their personal favorite
is now the ability,
with just a tap or two,
have a pizza show
up at your door.
They love that, much
sometimes to my dismay.
But it's just so
amazingly transformative
to see this change that's
happening around us,
and it's happening so fast and
yet for my young kids' life,
it's just all they've known.
This is the world they live
in, and they've just come
to expect this kind of reality.
And so it's, I think, easy to
take that for granted, even
though it's happening--
as it's happening so fast.
That's really why I love
working on mobile apps
and why I've chosen to
really focus on mobile apps
here at Google.
Mobile apps present such
an opportunity for you
to weave your products
into people's daily lives
and scale your businesses to
millions or even billions--
I'll say billions a lot today--
of people faster
than ever before.
We actually
announced yesterday--
if you think about the scale
of this transformation,
we announced
yesterday that people
have downloaded 82 billion apps
from the Play Store last year.
And the business
opportunities are growing.
We've also seen that the
number of buyers in Google Play
is growing by nearly 30
percent year over year.
So the opportunity is just
absolutely tremendous.
And of course, you all get that.
That's why you're here.
But since that opportunity
is true for everyone,
the question really becomes,
how do you rise above the noise
and get noticed?
Building a successful business
really takes more than just
making an awesome app.
That's really increasingly
become kind of table stakes.
I even know this firsthand.
When I started doing
mobile development,
it was on J2ME feature
phones back in the day.
This was before
there was app stores.
There was no way to do ads, to
market your apps to anybody.
We got, like, 3,000
users and wasn't
able to really go
anywhere with the app.
And even today, as the
opportunities have grown,
it's still--
the world is littered
with so many apps that
never really take off because
they're not able to find users
or make money.
And a lot of that is
because the competition
has gotten so fierce.
We've also measured that there
are-- the number of developers
with over one million installs
a month has grown by 35%
year on year.
So what this means is there's
a lot more competition
for people's attention
and their dollars.
And so you really have to
find a way to stand out
and while leaning on technology
to deliver more of the results
that you care about.
This is where Google
can really help you.
We have over half
a dozen properties
that each have over a
billion active users,
and so really
Google has the power
to find your users with
both simplicity and scale.
So today Belinda,
Rob, and I are going
to share strategies and
innovations that help you find
and keep more of your
best app customers.
Our presentation will
answer these questions
like, how do you grow
your user base quickly?
How do you find more
of your best customers?
How should you pay for them?
And how to make sure that
even after the install,
you can keep those users coming
back over and over to your app
and actually really making
a profit off your customers.
I'll kick things
off a little bit
by talking about growth, which
is such an essential part
of building a successful app.
You obviously didn't put
all that time and money
into developing your app just
to let it sit on the shelf.
So how do you put your apps
in the hands of more people
quickly?
Where and how can
you reach them?
For more and more of you, the
answer is starting with Google.
We recently shared that
Google has helped developers
and marketers just
like you drive over
five billion installs
via ads to date
for their mobile applications.
And our products aim
to place your app
in front of the right user
at exactly the right time.
A great example of how we can
do this is with Google Play.
So earlier this week
we also announced
that Android now reaches
two billion active users
every month, and the
Google Play Store
is available in 190 countries.
Really astounding scale.
Obviously Android users are
turning to the PlayStore
when they want to find a
great app or a great game.
And in addition to sometimes
going in and searching
for an application,
increasingly users
are actually getting
into the store,
browsing around, and finding app
recommendations surface to them
and getting their
apps as they're
browsing in the PlayStore.
We've obviously
noticed this trend.
And so to make sure we're
helping those users discover
your apps while
they're browsing,
we this week introduced
new ad placements
on the home and app listing
pages in the Google PlayStore.
These new placements
are exclusively
available through our
Universal App Campaigns, which
I'll talk a bunch
more on, and really
help you find the
users right when
they're ready and
willing to find your app.
And of course,
Google Play is just
one of the many
channels at Google
where users are finding apps.
They're finding apps and they're
watching videos on YouTube,
when they're checking emails,
when they're checking the news.
And this is why we built a
product we call Universal App
Campaigns, which we
affectionately call UAC,
to automatically reach
the billions of users,
whether they're in Google
Play, they're on google.com,
watching videos on YouTube,
checking mail on Gmail
or anywhere in the over
two million sites and apps
in the Google Display Network.
UAC really can simplify how you
reach your users when they're
ready to install the app.
For those of you who have
tried this prior to UAC,
you know that if you're
trying to find users
on, say, google.com, you
have to go in and figure out
which keywords are your
customers going to search for,
what kinds of
cost-per-click should you
pay for those keywords.
It's a very challenging process.
And that's just for google.com.
If you want to extend
that to, say, YouTube,
you have to think about which
audiences, which demographics
may resonate with your app, and
then show them those videos.
If you want to run on
the Display Network,
you might be
thinking about things
like what contacts matter
for your users, which apps,
which sites should
I be running on.
It's very tedious and complex
to do that across the board.
And so you're either
taking a lot of time
or you're missing out
on a lot of opportunity.
And so we decided with
UAC, rather than having
to manage all these
multiple campaigns
and doing all this manual
optimization across all
the different
channels and contexts,
UAC will automatically
do this for you
with a single campaign that
does all the heavy lifting.
A big theme here
at I/O, of course,
is AI and Machine Learning,
and there's no exception
when it comes to ads.
We've really extended
this technology
and brought it to
ads, and that's
the heart and soul of UAC
that makes us able to,
with a single campaign and
with very easy settings,
actually reach your users
across the Google ecosystem.
The reason this
works is because UAC
is able to get smarter
with every ad impression
and see how your users are
interacting with your app
and what's working
and what's not.
I'll give an example,
maybe your ad
is really resonating on
travel videos on YouTube.
So of course, then
the system will
make sure it's showing on
more channels like that,
or maybe this new
play ad is really
working out for you,
well, skew budget to that.
So it automatically
happens using data.
It's using all these
countless signals in real time
to continuously refine
your ads and make sure
that you're reaching the
right users at the right time
in the right place.
So my favorite example
of what UAC does
is figuring out
automatically that users
who have phones that
have low battery life
actually tend to not
install that many apps,
certainly not going to
install a really intense game.
But they do install
utilities, particularly
like battery savers.
And all the AI and
Machine Learning models
just figure this
out automatically
and make sure that the
right users are then
getting the right ads.
Or learn things like
weather apps are not
that popular in places where
the weather doesn't vary.
So in places like
Mountain View, you
might not see that
many ads for weather
apps from UAC, at least
not this time of year
with this kind of weather.
Universal App Campaigns
are really making it easier
for real companies, like HBO,
to really get their shows,
like Game of Thrones, Veep,
or my personal favorite,
of course, Silicon Valley in the
hands of their customers using
their HBO Now app.
Their vice president
of user acquisition,
Diana Pessin here is showing how
she's seen that Universal App
Campaigns make it so much
easier for her and her team
to reach the right
customers, cutting
the time it took to create these
campaigns from upwards of two
hours to down to
just 15 minutes,
and they're seeing great
results at the same time.
Obviously she, and I'm sure
you, can think of better things
to do with the hour
and 45 minutes you
save, whether it's building the
next great feature in your app
or working on your
business model
or just taking a bike
ride, as I like to do
right here around Shoreline.
Universal App
Campaigns are really
transforming the way
developers and marketers are
growing their apps.
So with UAC, you can put
Google's Machine Learning
to work for you and deliver
more trusted, invaluable results
for your business.
But it doesn't just
stop with the install.
It's all about getting
engaged users, driving value.
And so now I'm going to
turn it over to Belinda
here to talk about how Google
is helping you do that, driving
engagement and value while
making really profitable growth
decisions.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
BELINDA LANGNER: Great, awesome.
Thanks so much, David.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Belinda, and I'm a PM
here working on Universal App
Campaigns and app ads.
And while I haven't
been in Mountain View
as long as David
has, I certainly
have been working on app
ads for quite awhile.
And I remember even
just a couple years ago
when we started this most of you
guys were asking me questions
like, hey, how do I get
my app installed, right?
How do I get my app on
the homepage of users?
How do I become number
one in the top charts?
As David shared,
finding new users is
the critical part of
growing a successful app,
but growing that user base
and getting in the top charts,
they're great, but it
isn't the same thing
as building a
profitable business.
I was doing office hours earlier
today, and a bunch of you guys
have been coming over.
And again, the questions have
changed so much over the years.
And now the question
is, well, how do
I continue to grow my business?
And what we've been talking
about with a lot of you--
and feel free to
come over later too--
is that you need more engaged
customers to help you monetize,
and you need to be smart about
how you acquire these users
and how much you pay for them.
So I'm going to share
a little bit more
today about how Google is
helping you achieve both
of these goals, and by using
the knowledge you already
have about the great engaged
users you've already built up
and how you can continue to find
more of your best customers.
So like we've been
talking about,
you want users to not
just install the app,
but take additional steps
to engage of the app
that you and your team have
worked so hard to build.
You have so many cool
features in your app.
Don't let it just
sit on the phone.
You want people to take actions,
like booking a room so they
have a great weekend
getaway, or to slay a dragon
and beat the next level in the
really cool game that you built
out, or even just placing a
really great order for food
right after this talk is
over, because well, we happen
to be right before lunch.
So that's why last year we
introduced a new bidding option
for Universal App
Campaigns to help
you move beyond the install
and really focus and optimize
for those in-app convergence,
whatever that means
for you and your business.
And the goal is
really still the same.
We're still trying
to find you users.
We're trying to
find you new users.
But rather than focus on
things like what kinds of users
might eventually end up in your
app and do the right things,
we want you to just focus
on the actual events
that the users are actually
doing in your apps,
engaging with the
features you built out.
So the key thing for you to do
that is to fill in this blank
here.
What actions do you
want users to take
after they install your app?
Once you do that,
once you decide
that you want them
to slay some dragons
or that you want them to
place a food order delivery,
you can then define those
actions as convergence
and AdWords, and Google
actually evaluates
all the unique signals
that we have in real time,
combined with your
information, continuously
refining your ads
so that we show them
and promote your app
in the right place,
at the right price, across
all of Google's properties.
And this has been working
for app developers.
So I'm not sure how many of
you are familiar with Pixonic,
but they have this really
cool game called War Robots.
And it's a neat,
multi-player robot game,
and you really can't go
wrong with robots, right?
So by running UAC,
they ran a number
of campaigns optimizing for both
new installs and in-app users.
With this strategy,
they were able to scale
across 20 countries globally
and do so with a 63% higher ROI.
That is a lot of
fighting robots.
UAC is really
transforming the way
that developers, such as
Pixonic, and marketers
are acquiring the right
users, and it's also
changing how they work with
Google to promote their app.
In fact, one in four
app advertising dollars
today are already being spent
promoting in-app convergence
since we launched this new
bidding strategy in September.
And I'm really happy to say that
Google is helping developers
such as yourselves drive
over three billion events
per quarter, three billion.
That is more purchases
made, more levels
beat, more subscriptions, more
people taking more actions,
engaging with your
app, and really growing
to love the features that you
have worked so hard to build.
All those blood,
sweat, and tears,
all those late nights in
the office are worth it.
And we're hoping to accelerate
the delivery of this
to the developer community
such as yourselves
with even more enhanced
bidding strategies in UAC
that I'm going to go
ahead and talk about
and dive a little deeper into.
So in order to make
sure that you're
being smart with their
acquisition dollars,
we're introducing two
new bidding strategies
in Universal App
Campaigns, Target CPA,
cost-per-acquisition, and Target
ROAS, return on ads spends.
Simply put, these
strategies that you pay more
for users who are likely
to spend more, and pay less
for users who are
likely to spend less.
So let's go ahead and talk a
little bit more about them.
So we'll start with Target CPA
or Target cost-per-acquisition.
TCPA allows advertisers
to define the amount
that you want to pay for a
user who is likely to install
and perform a specific event.
So for a game like
Panda Pop here,
there's a number of events
that they care about.
They care about people beating
certain levels, completed
tutorial.
They want to make sure that
people are saving baby pandas,
and they also maybe want to
promote some of the rainbow
bubbles that they offer and
get more people to buy those.
So for Panda Pop,
they could bid,
for example, $10 for
an in-app purchase,
for people to buy
more rainbow bubbles,
or maybe they'll bid $5 for
a user who beats level one.
Then Universal App Campaigns
will take that information,
bid automatically
across all the channels,
to acquire users who
are likely to complete
that certain action, whether
it's beating level one
or buying more rainbow bubbles.
So for many of you, though,
events and convergence
don't tell the full story.
It's great that someone
buys them rainbow bubbles,
but some users buy a
lot of rainbow bubbles
and some buy a lot less.
So it's ultimately
about the revenue
that's generated from
these users with your app.
And that's why in addition
to just setting a Target CPA,
UAC advertisers will
now be able to bid
on Target ROAS for each
new app user acquired.
Target ROAS bidding
allows you to bid
more for users who are
even more valuable to you,
to distinguish between
users who only buy once
and users who buy multiple
times, between users who
buy smaller purchases
and between users
who buy larger purchases.
So I'll just give
an example here.
My brother and I, we really like
playing Trivia Crack together.
He lives over in DC and
I'm here in California.
So it's a great way
for us to sort of keep
our sibling rivalry going.
We're really competitive,
and I'm the older sister.
So I really want to make sure
that I'm beating my brother.
I can't let him win, right?
So I definitely buy a few
power-ups in Trivia Crack.
My brother, however,
is really busy,
and he doesn't really want to
deal with seeing ads too much.
And so he has actually bought an
ad-free version of Trivia Crack
so that he can
playing all the time.
While we both made purchases
within Trivia Crack,
we have made different
levels of purchases.
And so we are actually
valuable in different ways.
And so Trivia Crack should
pay perhaps a little bit more
to acquire me since I'll
keep buying more power-ups
while my brother is
pretty much done.
He's just not going to
win anymore against me.
So Google is built to understand
how valuable these users are
based on how they engage,
how they converge,
and how they spend
time within your app.
And Google has a
breadth of channels
to find more users that you
want to engage with your app
at scale.
So these options, Target
CPA and Target ROAS,
will be available later this
year for both iOS and Android
within UAC, and we're excited
to see how you use them
and how you get more users
to engage with your app.
But the shift to
engagement and value
makes real time
data and insights
even more important than ever.
Your first-party data is
informing the decisions
that you're making to
grow your business,
to decide which new
feature to build out,
which features to invest in
more, where are people really
growing to love your app.
And this becomes even
more difficult, though,
as you have more touch points to
think about and more customers
to keep track of.
And so Google has been
helping with Google Analytics
for Firebase, which
is a free tool that
allows you to track
your users real time
and what they're
doing within your app.
We also realize,
though, that many of you
have other measurement
partners that you're using,
and so we want to make
sure that you have
and we're committed to support
an open ecosystem of partners
that work well with our media.
So we're really happy to say
that we have been working
with seven app
attribution partners
to make measurement more
consistent and reliable
for app advertisers
such as yourselves.
Additionally, we also
want to make sure
that we streamlined the
process and a setup flow
for getting your data from
these app attribution partners
into AdWords.
So right now if you want to
get your data integrated,
it's really easy
to do, and you'll
be able to do that more quickly
and smoothly than ever before.
With easier access
to this data, you
can now make quicker and
smarter growth decisions,
and really focus on your app
and improving it and growing
even more.
And by combining this data
with Universal App Campaigns,
you now have a trusted way
to combine the insights
that you know and all
the work that you've
done to the power of
Google's Machine Learning.
And this has been
making a huge difference
in our customers' bottom lines.
Stash Invest is a
leading investment app,
and they were an early beta
tester of the app attribution
partner API.
They use a newly available
granular data with their ad
campaigns and Google's
Machine Learning
to find more users who are
likely to register and install
and open an account.
And this led to an 18% increase
in post-install convergence
rates.
So now we've covered
how to grow your app,
how to find more
valuable users, how
to get more people to
engage with all the features
that you built out.
But even if you get the right
users to install that app,
take that action,
you want to make
sure you have a strategy
for continually driving
re-engagement in
your app over time.
It's not just that
first purchase, but all
the other subsequent purchases.
So I'm going to go ahead and
hand the rock baton over to Rob
to tell you more about how
you can build a successful app
business by keeping users
coming back time and time again.
Thanks.
ROB AIKINS: Thanks, Belinda.
Hi, everyone.
I'm Rob, and I'm a product
manager here at Google,
working on our app
engagement products.
As Belinda mentioned,
I'm going to share
how Google is
innovating in many ways
to keep users
engaged in your app.
Naturally, we spend
a lot of time working
on the experience in our app.
We want to make sure
our apps are the best.
This is somewhat obvious.
The question is, how do
we delight users when
they are outside of our app?
I think this is best
illustrated with an example.
Imagine you have
the same business
you have now or the
same app, but imagine
you also have a brick and
mortar store with a big window.
Now, ask yourself, what should
you showcase in that window
so that when someone is walking
by, they stop and take a look?
What would you show to make
them not only take a look
but come in and make a purchase?
How would that change
for every single user?
This is a simplified example,
but the general philosophy
can make a big difference in
how you re-engage your users.
Getting users to
come back to your app
is all about connecting
those users with the products
that you provide that
they care about and love,
whether it's power-ups in
a game, deals on a hotel,
or the latest line of sneakers.
And doing this well requires
a customized message
and a personalized touch.
You need to understand how users
interact with your business
and what items in your
catalog they prefer,
as well as what actions
they take in order
to make a purchase.
Take e-commerce platform
Jet, for example.
The Jet mobile app
gives users an easy way
to browse products, view
prices, and purchase items
with the tap of a finger.
Let's look at the
way Lauren Picasso,
director of marketing at Jet,
thinks about re-engaging users.
She says, we're always looking
for delightful and relevant
ways to reach our customers
and bring them back
to engage in our app.
The marketing implications
of all of this
is you want to have insights
about your customers,
and you want to be able to
reach them in a timely manner
with personalized messages
that compel them to act.
And you want to do this for
all of your great products
and services that your
users care about at scale.
Google is helping you get
more users back into your apps
with innovations in our
re-engagement solutions.
I'm happy to announce that
AdWords advertisers can soon
extend their dynamic remarketing
campaigns to re-engage
their app users
with relevant ads
as they browse over two million
websites and apps on our Google
Display Network.
Let's imagine a hypothetical
example with Sam.
Sam wants to go to New
York for the weekend.
She's looking at flights while
in line at a coffee shop.
She doesn't finish the purchase
because her latte gets ready.
But with App
Dynamic Remarketing,
you can reach Sam with a
relevant and timely message
to remind her to book the trip.
This is a great
experience for Sam,
and this is great
for your business
because now she's booking that
flight inside of your app.
The fee-based
nature of these ads
mean that they're
perfect for businesses
that have a large
catalog of products,
whether that's running shoes,
hotel deals, or flight deals.
Wish is a retail app
that makes shopping fun.
Wish is part of our App
Dynamic Remarketing beta,
and they were impressed with the
high engagement and relevance
of the ads that were offered.
According to Peter, who's the
co-founder and CEO of Wish,
these ads help stretch
his team's budget further.
He says, being able to show
customized ads to our users,
based on past
interests, helps us
make the most of
every cent we invest.
But it's not just relevance
of ads that we're going for
and ad engagement.
It's really about
business impacts.
MakeMyTrip is a popular flight
booking service based in India.
People come to their
site and their app
to access great travel deals.
MakeMyTrip also took
part in our beta,
and our results suggest that
dynamic remarketing ads really
worked well for their app.
Google's App Dynamic
Remarketing ads
saw five times
higher convergence.
These are the actions that
drive MakeMyTrip's business,
especially in a mobile
first market like India.
We are encouraged with
the results of our beta,
and over the coming
months, we will
be rolling out these innovations
to AdWords advertisers
globally.
But driving engagement
you want from your apps
goes beyond just
reaching the right users
with the right message.
It requires delivering a
frictionless user experience
no matter where the
user's accessing your app.
As part of our
appification of our ads,
we will soon be making
it easier for people
to take actions in your app
from Google Mobile search ads.
We're providing new in--
we will be providing new
innovations for companies
that use ab links in their
Android adds to deep link users
to relevant content.
And for ads we'll make this work
for all versions of Android,
not just Android--
not just Marshmallow
and forward.
In another hypothetical
example, a Wish user Tom
would be able to click on
a search ad on google.com
and go back to the
page in the Wish app
that they were looking
at buying something,
and because their
information is already there,
all of their preferences
there, he has a very easy time
to make that convergence,
and drive additional value
for your business.
With re-engagement ads, we'll
be able to find users and bring
them back to your app.
We'll be able to drive
additional value beyond just
the install and
make sure that you
get the most out of the
users that have your app.
In closing, we've
come a long ways
from the days of interacting
with brands solely
in real world environments.
Today we have the
opportunity to engage
with our users
across the world just
from the palm of
their hands, and we
have relationships
that span years,
instead of days or months.
You have a massive opportunity
to reach more customers
and drive more revenue and
value through your mobile app,
and building
successful apps that
support your business doesn't
have to be hard work anymore.
We want to make it easier for
you to bring your unique app
data, and our intent signals
and context knowledge
in a way that lets you
delight your customers
and find them at the right time.
The good news is not only do
we have access to more customer
signals and data than ever, we
have the most critical piece
and that is the ability
to use all of this data.
Machine Learning and
Google's innovative products
like Universal App Campaigns
and our re-engagement solutions
allow us to bring the right
message to the right user
at the right time.
And this makes it easy to get
them to where they want to go,
and that's into your
apps to make purchases.
So app technology is
really becoming the enabler
that it was promised to be
and not just another channel
that you have to figure out.
We look forward to seeing
how you can take advantage
of all of our recent
innovations to connect
to more of your
users and drive more
value from your mobile apps.
On behalf of Belinda
and David and myself,
I'd like to thank
you for your time,
and we'll now open
it up to questions.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]